hello and please welcome to this video
everything a late start here against
Michael Hennigan let's see if i can get
this funky attacking scheming again with
with h5 could be many players counselor
to this and don't really reckon that h5
is going to happen but it is happening
even after before you can play it so I'm
going to be an interesting game out I
have this vague idea that I had this on
the board against him before interesting
fire oh well okay taking wasn't working
because of Crean 84 @ h forward a little
bit quickly a bit little bit quickly
played but then the gate is consistent
is he giving up d for Nia I mean I'm not
sure that is really a problem frame I
just wonder this is also something quite
annoying for white yeah so I can even
think about 26 in this position I wonder
no it's probably not a great idea but I
don't I don't quite see why I shouldn't
take the pawn I mean I lose some time
that is that it's clear of it maybe I
can do it Queen at six years 95
unfortunately otherwise that would be a
pretty decent move I don't know
I think I rather let this pawn and keep
the detect let's say and try to take it
again with night at five I think this is
probably better he has no good way of
covering this problem anyway like night
of neck Bishop e3 at night at five not
so easy for what to play quite a messy
position d 5 is always answered with 95
that looks really good for black so that
just makes no sense at all yeah I'm
getting pressure on d4 now yeah yeah I
can take I wonder if I should take
something like rook e8 like an extra key
aide is also not bad just put more
pressure and if it mainly cannot move as
Bishop away as defaults hanging with a
couple of big four yeah this one is the
ship e six maybe or just take it
yeah you should be six doesn't doesn't
do all that much huh I can take with i
can simply take on you three yeah but I
don't know if that's just it does much
okay I'm not playing this movie need to
trade this epsilon cook to come under
fire but III is really really really
really weak we should h5 this just says
just something I did not evaluate
correctly i was thinking g6 but it runs
into a big Fork ok but en c 6
you
yeah maybe I should take with the hook
actually all right I better take with
the book I think he will take on these
seven I don't really see something else
retreating is wrong I have 95 them so
that cannot be right unless there is
some tactic that i'm not saying i'm
going to edit it looks entirely wrong
how do you play now if or maybe equals e
four so i probably have to close this
down and then play night at five ever
that we can the lotto doesn't it have
seven is weaker for me I have to check
anyway
I don't nobody can do anything else
there it is hanging there's the bishop
yeah let's remove it always screws up
the screen somewhat dad looks a bit
strange that primo picture it's
difficult and I'll clean d 3 or
something maybe now okay so i probably
have to anchor this one yeah cool 71 and
93
yes he seeks is somewhat hanging here
right difficulty in 378 place 93 maybe i
was thinking i can even check on c5 then
it's not really working all that well ok
so these six clicking on take this and
center is kind of falling apart here I
was very complicated him I don't know I
cannot believe I was wrong at the
beginning of all this but somehow it
turned it turned them turned out to be
bad time morning she threatening to take
and no one can take c5 check ok I have
to go for full-scale activity here and
I'm not sure about all this d 6 is
weekend all my pieces now I active
I think I'm fine now there's also the
time my case got this 757 what do I do
now I should take this takes tanks I
came up calculators and then but okay if
he moves the night I can take windey 50
no I cannot do that ah ah come on okay
okay I could check medical with rook see
one like I when I had to enter that my
god I was a super complicated position
somehow I really don't know what was
going on down right from the opening it
was extremely talk so he avoided the
counseling mistake on 17 a lady form
yeah after before i'm really not sure
when I analyzed this a little bit h5 was
a good move obviously sharp or taking
actually that also something that comes
into consideration play like this for
potential night at five it's far more
solid before is it cool reply I mean and
now I just probably teach you take on on
H on d4 first now because capturing is
just better to have right like here
yeah yeah here I don't know what's going
on stockfish likes black now that it is
entirely messy I can take that's what
the engine is giving it as you see this
is a strong piece this is a strong piece
I just need the Queen on h5 and the game
is over somehow not sure that I get down
with them yeah so I decided to not take
immediately but try to improve that I
like this during the game maybe it
really is doing all that much so six and
I am if all looks looks loose but it is
access it's very active and this was
good as well and now its synthesis I
engine wants to go 9 h 6 I guess g6 is
problematic the engine just wants to
grab the pawn I'll remove that didn't
occur to bother whether I guess this
will completely logical ok applied this
93 85 no Bishop d7 d8 could have one
with taking
I just wanted to capture here but he's
got the night Jean I hey I'm gonna kill
them I cannot check that was lucky you
should have five now I was an idea i was
thinking i always get good enough here I
mean yeah you know it's a big gamble you
ever take a little time cannot calculate
them all or probably any way over here
26 was possible haha general field I
should should be okay yeah it looks very
active and D success is weak but Luke
see one seems to hold ya hear ya sorry
can ya hear all of a sudden I wasn't in
some issues and this he has d7 I saw
this and then I thought queen of two
maybe but he i felt i'm even losing f
with Queenie aid check but I can
actually do this so Bishop takes the
seven takes days and you'll see one is a
draw okay I just want to just wanted to
continue somehow it ah this is extremely
problematic npn I have six was probably
winning in and we were completely
scrambling here I can take a checkmate
efficiently yeah but you can we just
move oh okay that was a crazy game
thanks for watching